on the ai front
if we just link an effort yeah uh so
you're
friends with you often talk with the
elon musk throughout history you've
uh did a lot of interesting things
together um he has a
a set of fears about the future of
artificial intelligence
agi do you have a sense
you've we've already talked about the
things we should be worried about with
ai do you have a sense of the shape of
his spheres
in particular about ai
of the which subset of what we've talked
about whether it's
creating you know it's that direction of
creating
sort of these giant competition systems
that are not explainable
they're not intelligible intelligence or
is it um is it the
and then like as a branch of that is it
the manipulation by
big corporations of that or individual
evil people
to use that for destruction or the
unintentional consequences
do you have a sense of where his
thinking is on this from
my many conversations with elon yeah i
i certainly have a model of how how he
thinks it's actually very
much like the way i think also i'll
elaborate on it a bit i just want to
push back on when you said evil people i
i don't think it's very helpful context
concept evil people yes sometimes people
do very very bad things
but they usually do it because they
think it's a good thing yes
because somehow other people had told
them that that was a good thing or given
them
incorrect information or or whatever
right um i
have i believe in the fundamental
goodness of humanity that if we
educate people well and they find out
how things really are
people generally want to do good and be
good
hence the value alignment as yeah it's
it's
about information about knowledge and
then once we have that we'll
we'll uh we'll likely be able to
uh do good in the way that's aligned
with everybody else who thinks
yeah and it's not just the individual
people we have to align so
we we don't just want people to
be educated to know the way things
actually are and to treat each other
well
but we also need to align other
non-human entities we talked about
corporations there has to be
institutions so that what they do is
actually good for the country they're in
and
we should align do make sure that what
countries do is actually good for
the species as a whole etc uh coming
back to elon yeah
my my um understanding of of
how elon sees this is really quite
similar to my own which is
one of the reasons i like him so much
and enjoy talking with him so much i
think he's
quite different from most people in that
he
thinks much more than most people about
the really big picture
not just what's going to happen in the
next election cycle but
in millennia millions and billions of
years from now
right and if you when you look in this
more cosmic perspective it's so obvious
that we're gazing out into this universe
that as far as we can tell
is mostly dead with life being almost
imperceptibly tiny perturbation right
and
and he sees this enormous opportunity
for our universe to come alive
for us to become an interplanetary
species mars is obviously just
first stop on this cosmic
journey and precisely because he thinks
more long-term
it's much more clear to him than to most
people that what we do with this russian
roulette thing we keep playing with our
nukes
as a really poor strategy really
reckless strategy
and also that that we're just building
these ever more powerful ai systems that
we don't understand
it's also it's a really reckless
strategy i feel elon is a human
very much a humanist in the sense that
he wants an awesome
future for humanity he wants to be
us that control the machines
rather than the machines that control us
yes you know
and why shouldn't we insist on that
we're building them after all right
why should we build things that just
make us into some little cog in the
machinery that has no further say in the
matter right it's not my idea of
an inspiring future either yeah the if
if you think on the cosmic scale in
terms of both time and space
so much is put into perspective yeah
whenever i have a bad day that's what i
think about it immediately makes me feel
better
it makes me sad that for us individual
humans
at least for now the ride ends too
quickly
we don't get to experience the cosmic
scale
yeah i mean i think of our universe
sometimes as an organism that has only
begun to wake up a tiny bit
uh just like you know the very first
little glimmers of consciousness you
have in the morning when you start
coming around for the coffee
before the coffee even before you get
out of bed before you even open your
eyes
you start start to wake up a little bit
there's something here you know
uh that's very much how i think of of
where we are you know those all those
galaxies out there you know i think
they're
really beautiful but why are they
beautiful
they're beautiful because conscious
entities are actually
observing them and experiencing them
through our telescopes
if i you know i define consciousness
as subjective experience whether it be
colors or emotions or sounds
so beauty is an experience meaning is an
experience
purpose is an experience if there was no
conscious experience
of observing these galaxies they
wouldn't be beautiful if if we do
something dumb
with advanced ai in the future here and
earth originating life goes extinct
and that was it for this if there is
nothing else with telescopes in our
universe then
it's kind of game over for me beauty and
meaning and purpose in our whole
universe and i think that would be just
such
an opportunity lost frankly and i think
when elon points this out he gets very
unfairly
maligned in the media for all the dumb
media bias reasons we talked about right
they want to print precisely the things
about elon out of context
that are really click-baity like he has
gotten so much flack
for this summoning the demon statement
yeah i happen to know exactly the
context because i was in the front row
when they gave that talk it was at mit
you'll be pleased to know it was the
aero astro
anniversary they had buzz aldrin there
from the moon landing
a whole house crazy auditorium packed
with mit students
and he had this amazing q and a it might
have gone for an hour and then we
talked about rockets and mars and
everything at the very end
this one student was actually in my
class asked him what about ai
elon makes this one comment and they
take this out of context
print it goes viral is it like with ai
we're summoning the demon something like
that
and trying to cast him as some sort of
doom and gloom dude you know
yeah you know elon yes he's not the doom
and gloom
dude he he is such a positive visionary
and the whole reason he warns about this
is because he realizes more than most
what the opportunity cost is of screwing
up that there is so much awesomeness in
the future that we can
we can and our descendants can enjoy if
we don't screw up right
i get so pissed off when people try to
cast him in some sort of
technophobic luddite and and
at this point it's kind of ludicrous
when when i hear people say that people
who worry about
artificial general intelligence are
luddites because
of course if you look more closely you
have some of the most
outspoken people making warnings are
people like professor stuart russell
from berkeley who's written the
best-selling ai textbook you know
so claiming that he is a luddite who
doesn't understand ai
is the joke is really on the people who
said it but i think more broadly
this message is really not sunk in at
all
what it is that people worry about they
think that elon
and stuart russell and others are
worried about
the dancing robots picking up an
ar-15 and going on a rampage right
they think they're worried about robots
turning evil
they're not i'm not no the risk is not
malice it's competence the risk is just
that we build some systems that are
incredibly competent which means they're
always going to get
their goals accomplished even if they
clash with our goals
that's the risk why did we humans you
know drive the
west african black rhino extinct is it
because we're malicious evil
rhinoceros haters no it's just because
our goals didn't align with the goals of
those rhinos and
tough luck for the rhinos you know so
what i'm the point is just we don't want
to put ourselves in the position of
those rhinos
creating these something more powerful
than us
if we haven't first figured out how to
align the goals and i am optimistic i
think we could do it if we worked really
hard on it because
i spent a lot of time around intelligent
entities that were more intelligent than
me
my mom and my dad and i was little and
that was fine
because their goals were actually
aligned with mind quite well
but we've seen today many examples of
where the goals of our powerful systems
are not so aligned so those
click through optimization algorithms
that are polarized social media right
they were actually
pretty poorly aligned with what was good
for democracy it turned out
and um again almost all problems we've
had in machine learning again came
so far not from malice but from poor
alignment and it's
that's exactly why that's why we should
be concerned about it in the future
you